♪♪
Narrator: JESSE, RACHEL,
AND VALERIE ARE TESTING
THE TACKIEST OF MYTHS.
OH, WOW.
CAN A BUG GLUE TRAP BE SCALED UP
TO A SIZE
THAT CAN CAPTURE A HUMAN?
Rachel: THAT'S A MAYBE.
Narrator: THEY'VE ALREADY PICKED
THEIR TOP ADHESIVE...
-OHH!
-THIS ONE IS DEFINITELY STICKY.
Narrator:
...A NONTOXIC RODENT GLUE.
TIME TO GET COOKING IN
THE MYTHBUSTERS TEST KITCHEN,
WHERE THE SEMISOLID SUBSTANCE
NEEDS TO BE HEATED UP
BEFORE IT'S POURED OUT...
ALL RIGHT.
LET'S DO ANOTHER POUR.
IT LOOKS LIKE
WE'RE READY.
...INTO A MID-SCALE
PROOF-OF-CONCEPT RUNWAY.
ALL RIGHT.
HERE WE GO.
OH, MY GOD.
SO IMAGINE LIKE 200 GUM
STUCK TO YOUR SHOE
ON A HOT SUMMER DAY.
UGH.
-YES.
-UGH.
YOU MADE IT!
Narrator: RACHEL AND VALERIE
ARE SOLD ON THE RODENT GLUE.
I BET YOU $5 YOU CAN'T
RUN THROUGH THIS.
-$20.
-THAT'S $25.
-$5.
-$25.
Narrator: THE FINAL YEA OR NAY
FOR THE RODENT GLUE
HAS COME DOWN TO THIS.
THREE, TWO, ONE.
MUCH TO HIS CHAGRIN,
JESSE ENDS UP FACE-FIRST...
MY SOCK GOT STUCK.
...FOOTWEAR-FREE...
Rachel: THAT WAS THE FUNNIEST
THING I'VE SEEN ALL DAY.
...AND 25 BUCKS POORER.
OKAY, WELL, I THINK
WE FOUND OUR GLUE.
WE DIDN'T GET STUCK, BUT
HOPEFULLY WHEN WE SUPERSIZE THIS
AND THE GLUE THICKENS,
MAYBE WE WILL.
I'M GONNA NEED THESE.
UGH.
OH, MY GOD.
OKAY.